Bonsoir, Monsieur Taillon.
- Bonsoir, Monsieur Roy.
- On s'est parlé avant la
conférence de presse et vousça
donne un coup. C'est la fin deau
niveau juridique, les pouvoirs
accrus aux policiers sont iers d
mênts. On peut enlever
les permis, fermé des comptes dr
chercher le camion. N'y a-t-il
à des outils
supplémentaires pour les
policiers?
- On ne sait pas ce dont les
crise, puisqu'on ne les a
pas laissés le travailler depuis
le dle dle dle dle début. Il ese
l'état d'urgence va permettre de
créer de nouvellesdéjà des chost
interdite et que lesmanifestante
temporaire, interdiction de
manifester poste frontalier,
certains lieux. Le droit
déjà cela, mais ça va rendre les
choses explicitées ça va être
utile. Là où le gouvernement
sera rapidement sur la
défensive, c'est que les
critères pour cette loi, la loi
est très exigeante. Elle exige
de démontrer qu'
juridiques. C'est difficile de
dire qu'il manqutilstilstilstils
dans le coffre quand depuis deux
semaines on a utilisé aucun des
outils à la disposition. Il a
même été n Tahoua
demandent une injonction, parce
que les autoriues n'en
demandaient pas. Ça va être
difficile de prouver que le
coffre Haïti était insuffisant.
À Wà Québeà Québeà Québeà Québet
la preuve que les outils normaux
pouvaient produire des
résult
- Vousque le gouvernement
n'avait pas fait la preuve.
- C'est l'argument que les
nts vont mobiliser. Le
gouvernement a été passé en
début de crise pour de bonnes
ster, et aussi pour des
raisons tactiques, laissersition
sujet polarisant à l'intérieur
du Parti conservateur. Mais làçt
d'ultimatum pour dire que la
ce besoin qui cherche à Bourgon
combler l'état d'urgence.
- Comme la police d'Ottawa n'a
pas bien fait son travail, c'est
un fait, les nouveaux pouvoirs
la GRC des pouvoirs dans une
juridiction municipale com
Ottawa et la GRC pourrait
pallier plus facilement le
manque de force de la poli
Tahoua.
- Le pouvoir d'u
permet... dans lsssssssss
jours, on avait une chicane des
compétences. On se renvoyait la
balle pour agir. À partir de
maintenant, la police fédérale
aura les pleins pouvoirs et ne
pourraière
le fait que c'est à la police
d'Ottawa d'agir. Dans le cas de
la ville d'Ottawa, il y a des
rues qui sont de
compétence fédérale et d'autres
qui sont de compétence
municipale. Ce n'est pas un gros
problème quand il y a de laatioe
qu'on va aller au-delà de ça. La
loi exige de consulter les
provinces et voir si le
gouvernement s'entête à
appliquer son état d'urgence
dans des provinces qui n'en
veulent pas. Pour l'instant, lee
qu'on va agir dans les
compétences fédérales, poste
frontalier et aéroport. Ça va,
on est dans des enclaves
fédérales. La province de
l'Ontario semble vouloir de
l'état d'urgence pour sortir de
la crise. Il faudra être très
attentif à si on essai
d'appliquer l'état d'urgence, ce
sera une pente glissante pour le
gouvernement Trudeau.
- Mais les provinces qui n'en
ont pas besoin, ne l'utiliseront
pas. C'est un peu la réponse de
Trudeau.
- Part
compétences fédérales, ça va
bien. Il y a des aéroports
fédéraux en territoire québécois
c'est y
applique mais il n'y a pas lieu
de donner la gestion des
olice
fédérale alors qu'il n'y a pas
de problème et que les promesses
ne sont pas en demande. Il faut
que les progrès soient consultés
et il faut que la province soit
dans l'incapacité d'agir. Quand
tout le monde est d'accord, ça
va très bien pour démontrer
qu'il y a besoin, mais du moment
où il y a des provinces qui
disent qu'ils n'ont pas de
besoin qu'elles n'en veulent
pas, ça devient plus difficile.-
être de l'Alb
Québec, il y a eu une
manifestation ça s'est bien
déroulé. L'Ontario ne peut pas
plaider qu'il savait
parfaitement le contrôle de
tous.
- À Windsor, Ontario fait la
démonsàààààààààààààà
dimanche que leurs outils
étaient suffisants. Mais le
pas
fait la même démarche dans la
ville de Tahoua et il semble
vouloir de cet état d'urgence et
il semble vouloir coopérer. Pour
résoudre la crise en Ontario et
dans la région d'Ottawa, ça vabs
autres provinces ont cherché à
l'appliquer à des lieux qui ne
sont pas de compétence fédérale
qu'on pourrait s'embarquer dans
une situation délicate. C'état p
plus encadrée qu'au niveau
provincial et la chambre des
communes va joue
important. Nul doute que
l'opposition officielle et peut-
être même
bloc québécois risque d'être
autant contre la chose que le
premier ministre du Québec. Le
NPD, il faudra voir.
- La réaction des conservateurs
est inconnue, mais le NPD a dit
démarche. Ils ont la major